This is a,
not only a course for English majors,
but for other majors to the poets we'll be reading.
Well,
they,
uh,
they knew about science,
music,
politics,
economics,
and they presume to talk about those things,
uh,
in their poetry and out of their poetry to,
my lectures,
uh,
are going to presume no special knowledge,
on your part.
Uh,
I,
uh,
I see this as a a course that's an introduction to the literature of a period,
to modern poetry.
Uh,
the,
uh,
we'll be studying several poets in some detail.
Um,
uh,
they,
presumption as well that they,
they all,
uh,
reward and,
and demand a certain amount of,
of close reading.
Uh,
at the same time,
I do mean to give you some sense of the period in which they're writing,
uh,
some sense of modernism as a,
as a field,
as one of the richest fields in,
in English language writing.
Uh,
finally though,
uh,
this really is a course in poetry,
plain and simple.
I mean,
to,
uh,
introduce you to particular poems,
to give you ways to possess them,
uh,
enjoy them.
Uh,
be,
uh,
puzzled or,
or frustrated by them to,
uh,
to learn something from them,
and to care about them and to carry them with you as you,
as you go forward,
uh,
after this class.
So,
uh,
that's a sense of what I want to,
accomplish in these lectures.
Uh,
it will mean reading a lot of poems,
uh,
in writing about them.
Some,
uh,
the syllabus,
you'll see notes,
that general topic of each lecture,
uh,
and the reading that I,
I want you to have done for that day.
Uh,
there's a midterm,
uh,
that will be a short answer test.
That's a intended to give you a chance to show how diligently you've been
reading and coming to class.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the final,
will include both,
uh,
a short answer component.
And then some essay questions.
There are two papers,
uh,
a shorter and a slightly longer one.
Uh,
the first paper is going to ask you to write about one short poem.
the second we'll ask you to write about a two or more poems or poems,
perhaps by two authors or perhaps a poem.
And some other kind of text or image,
uh,
the,
teaching fellows in this course.
I'm lucky to work with you to,
uh,
they,
are trained in,
have had an interest in modern poetry.
Uh,
and,
and this is,
uh,
a,
a happy collaboration for me with them.
Uh,
as I say,
we'll start to get our discussion sections organized on Monday.
Uh,
and they should be set,
I hope by the Wednesday lecture next week.
I want you to come to lecture on time.
G,
while did today.
I started on time.
I don't always do that.
Uh,
but I'd like to,
uh,
and I can,
if you come,
uh,
at 1130 bring your books,
I'm going to be talking about the texts and I hope you'll have them open.
Uh,
and,
and of course you will come to your discussion sections in the same state of
joyful preparedness.
Uh,
and as I say,
the,
the syllabus is,
uh,
should be accessible on the class classes vitu server.
However,
I've had problems with that in the past and you should please let me know if
it's not.
Uh,
they are just two books for the course.
they're both at labyrinth.
Uh,
one is,
uh,
the first volume of the Norton Anthology of modern and contemporary poetry.
Third Edition.
Uh,
it's edited by Johanne Ramezani,
formerly a teaching fellow in this course.
Uh,
there's also,
uh,
Elizabeth Bishop's collected poems.
Uh,
there will be a packet that you can order from Ras that's,
uh,
gathers a few supplementary readings.
Uh,
there will be the visual images that I'm going to talk about in lecture,
uh,
and then I will make accessible to you on the class of server.
Uh,
they're also,
uh,
audio recordings of,
of the poets that we will be reading that come from sterling.
Uh,
and,
and you can get to on the center for language study,
website,
all those things.
Uh,
uh,
we can,
talk about,
uh,
more as the semester develops.
Uh,
and I hope you will talk to me.
you can do that on email.
You can do that,
uh,
in my office,
which is downstairs in the first floor of this building in a LC one oh nine,
uh,
you can catch me after lecture or,
or before.
Uh,
we can have lunch,
uh,
all sorts of,
um,
opportunities,
uh,
for talking and,
and,
uh,
I hope you'll take advantage of it.
Uh,
for Monday we're going to start talking about Robert Frost.
and,
and I'd like you to,
um,
uh,
pay special attention to his poem mowing in the Ras Packet,
and to his palm birches in the Norton.
Um,
as you read,
pay a special attention to images of tools,
work,
uh,
play,
read Frost's,
uh,
short poetic statement,
pros,
poetic statement,
uh,
in the,
in the Norton called,
uh,
the figure poem mix.
So,
uh,
the Norton Anthology,
this book,
uh,
this heavy book,
I ordered it as a,
as a way to,
um,
uh,
well reduce your expenses.
Here's just one big book to buy.
Uh,
it also provides needed annotation.
modern poetry is in need of annotation.
Uh,
this,
this new addition of this old book,
um,
is,
is an excellent one.
You should read Johanne Ramezani's introduction,
uh,
read his pros notes.
Uh,
you know,
that preface his various selections.
Uh,
having said that,
uh,
there's really nothing so dead as a Norton Anthology,
you know,
uh,
or,
or ponderous,
uh,
and,
you know,
I,
I do order it with a little,
uh,
um,
well some misgivings,
uh,
for that.
Uh,
the palms come to you abstracted from the contexts in which they were originally
produced a and read,
uh,
you know,
from,
from their place in a body of work,
in a book,
in a magazine,
uh,
in a life that,
produced,
uh,
the,
um,
in order to counteract the packaged in monumental form of,
of the Norton,
uh,
I will be using binary keys and sterling's resources,
using a PowerPoint,
a digitized files,
uh,
this whole,
allow me to project images,
uh,
in class and for you to look at them later,
at home,
uh,
there'll be files for not all,
but most of the poets that we,
uh,
discuss,
in the aim is to give you some sense through those images of modern poetry in
its historical material,
uh,
dimensions,
to,
to represent it as,
as something that was lived,
uh,
and in many ways is living now.
Now,
uh,
the poems that you'll be reading we'll be talking about did not,
of course,
oh,
eggs exist in the form that you find them.
Uh,
their first form was very often a manuscript.
if you go to buy Nikki,
you can,
you can find a,
and we will go to binding.
[inaudible] those of you who want to come with me,
uh,
and,
and look at,
um,
uh,
manuscripts that were early versions of texts that you now find in the Norton
and other books,
uh,
when poems that had gone through their processes of revision and so forth and
came to publication,
they very often,
uh,
were published first,
not in book form,
certainly,
uh,
but rather in little magazines that are now more or less loss to us today,
but were in fact the,
uh,
essential vehicle for the creation of modern poetry.
Uh,
what is a little magazine?
it is,
um,
well,
very often they were big,
uh,
you know,
begin in format and size.
Um,
they were little because their circulation was small.
Uh,
these were the funded on a shoe string,
uh,
magazines that,
rose up and,
and very frequently faded away just as quickly,
uh,
in the 1910 in 1920s.
Uh,
and that were in many cases,
the first avenue of publication for Steven's Elliot.
Uh,
more,
uh,
the poem poets that you will be reading in this class.
These magazines were
acutely aware of their differences from the popular literary magazines of the
19th century.
Uh,
general interest,
a popular magazines of the 20th century,
uh,
magazines with wide circulation,
polite audiences.
Uh,
the little magazine was written to by address to new young writers and artists,
uh,
and they were determined to make trouble.
They,
uh,
well the,
the,
uh,
nothing I think captures the nerve of,
these magazines like the cover of blast blast,
which meant Kaboom,
a magazine as a kind of bomb,
a kind of bomb or maybe a curse.
Damn you blast.
Uh,
pound was one of the,
uh,
contributors,
Elliot's rhapsody on a windy night,
a period here in,
uh,
this number of the magazine,
from 1915
July,
1915 in the midst of the first World War,
uh,
rogue,
another also from 1915.
Notice the price 5 cents,
uh,
Steevens appeared here in this magazine.
You could contrast the rogue Gish and fanciful,
uh,
clearly done by hand title of the magazine with that machine type blast.
Uh,
uh,
both of these are,
are,
are mischievous,
oppositional,
uh,
magazines,
but with very different styles and attitudes.
Okay.
Here's another
room.
Uh,
this is a magazine just slightly later.
this is an issue of 1922.
Uh,
it's a cover by a fair [inaudible].
J Hart Crane would appear here.
A broom broom meant to make a clean sweep of things,
a clean sweep of what had come before.
Uh,
it,
uh,
it also clearly meant to have fun doing it here.
Whoops,
let me,
uh,
I've gone too far.
This is the back of the magazine.
You can,
I don't know how well you can make it out,
but there's a,
there's a little broom guy there with glasses,
uh,
playing air guitar with his broom.
Uh,
and,
and I guess this is meant to capture the spirit of the contributors.
Uh,
uh,
contrast that with
all right.
And magazine that flashed their a moment ago.
The criterion,
this is a long way from broom.
Uh,
this is October,
1922,
uh,
comes out just before Broome has created a,
here you've got a magazine that doesn't present itself as attacking anything.
At all,
uh,
but rather as what,
as setting the standard,
the criterion,
it looks official.
It doesn't,
it,
uh,
the editor is
ts Eliot.
Uh,
this is the first number of the magazine.
The magazine in many ways announced and facilitated Elliot's rise to a kind of
cultural authority as a tastemaker.
Uh,
and with it a certain ideas of modernism.
this,
uh,
issue here October,
1922 includes the way slam by PSLE yet.
Uh,
it also includes a little bit further down the page,
a review an essay by Valerie Lara bow on a new novel by James Joyce called
Ulysses.
Uh,
that's some sense of the spectrum of,
of magazines that are,
that are coming out all with,
with,
uh,
different roles to play in this culture,
in that position there they're writers and poets and artists associated with
them in different ways.
Book publication can be just as interesting and it can tell us just as much
about modern poetry and his magazines.
This is the wind among the reeds,
author William Butler Yeats,
uh,
the year 1899 on the verge of the new century.
It's a beautiful book.
It's a book that wants to be beautiful,
uh,
that's happy to be beautiful.
Uh,
it's rich in color and texture.
it's designed embossed guilt.
It's well self,
consciously Irish,
Celtic.
Uh,
there,
there's a sense that you're supposed to leave the bookstore with it,
with a kind of talisman that you,
you have,
you have bought,
uh,
with,
a Celtic charm.
Contrast
this book
Prufrock uh,
and other observations.
The subtitle left off here of the cover of ts Elliot's a great book published in
1917.
Mm.
This is a different,
different object,
isn't it?
Severe unsentimental dry.
Uh,
so much so as to be maybe even a little bit funny.
And you laughed,
right?
Uh,
and I think you're supposed to,
uh,
it's not entirely serious.
Uh,
even as it declares its seriousness if Yates is book was so explicitly Irish.
Look at this book.
Uh,
it has no observable nationality at all.
Does it?
A certain kind of,
well,
you might say,
ah,
impersonality uh,
it's rhetoric is so flat and unemotional.
Uh,
uh,
so overtly UN rhetorical,
it is in fact a very deliberate and self-conscious repudiation of that late
romantic aesthetic that Yates is early book.
And even the cover of that early book represents Prufrock isn't beautiful.
Uh,
in its author is not a bard.
Another book,
another book cover the weary blues by Langston Hughes.
1926,
uh,
unlike Prufrock,
this one is full of color.
Uh,
and of course it is the work of a poet of color.
the image presents the book not as a work of poetry at all,
uh,
but rather as a kind of music,
as,
as a book of Blues,
uh,
in it associates.
Uh,
it's poet singer with honkytonk piano,
not brooms,
Bohemian egg head air guitarist.
Uh,
but,
uh,
another kind of a vernacular,
another kind of,
um,
well celebration and,
and,
um,
uh,
another kind of music
makes us think about black artists playing for living in prohibition era,
back rooms.
Now,
poems,
uh,
like books
project an image of the poet who produces them,
uh,
while the poet is creating her or his poems.
The poet is also creating a poet,
a certain figure of the poet,
a public image of the poet.
And this is an evolving project,
a work in progress that's part of the work and part of the subject.
And part of what I will be talking about here,
let's look for example,
at a series of photos of Ezra pound
together,
they tell a kind of encapsulated history of this central fascinating,
problematic poets career.
Uh,
he begins as well as an aesthete.
This is 1913 pound and the London,
uh,
styling himself,
isn't he a,
after those renaissance artists and poets,
uh,
whom he would,
write about translate,
uh,
in this period it could be a miniature worn by a province.
Saul Damsel.
No.
Well,
here he is,
a little later pound after the war,
uh,
in a,
1923,
uh,
and I've sort of full flower of modernism.
Uh,
still a young man,
but he's got that cane.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
he's in Paris,
where,
uh,
he would meet,
Elliot and work on the wasteland with him.
Well,
fast forward 20 years,
this has pound pound accused of treason,
pound accused of treason by his country,
uh,
accused of treason as he tries to bend the world to his vision of it.
And he escapes trial only by reason of insanity when he is brought from Italy,
uh,
under charges of,
of having a maid,
broadcasts on Fascist Radio,
uh,
back to the United States after an ordeal in,
a cage in Piza where,
uh,
he,
poses for this photo,
uh,
as an intake photo,
as he enters Saint Elizabeth Hospital for the insane in Washington.
In this final photo photo from 1971 back in Italy and Apollo well,
here's pound,
uh,
and,
presenting us with an image of something that would have seemed impossible when
he began,
which is an image of modernism grown old,
uh,
old and,
and,
and blasted.
No,
uh,
in many senses.
Contrast this,
this career,
uh,
encapsulated in those images with this one.
Who's this?
This is,
uh,
the author of Prufrock and peck.
This is the Harvard student who wrote Prufrock.
I mean that Eliot wrote Prufrock largely when,
uh,
still at Harvard.
And then in the years immediately following
sexy,
a little,
uh,
maybe,
those full,
slightly parted lips,
uh,
that wind swept hair.
The,
the general j crew look,
uh,
notice the handkerchief,
here is the editor.
If,
uh,
a great editor,
a of the publisher,
a faber and Faber,
30 years later or more,
uh,
surrounded by books,
the cultural arbiter of the English speaking world,
Tsla at 60,
uh,
that hair is now slicked down,
their glasses between him and us.
Uh,
this is the young man who's become a monument.
but really the costume is the same one,
right?
There's the handkerchief
pounds,
descent into infamy and insanity and indignity and Elliot's rise to the
extraordinary cultural power,
uh,
and prestige that he occupied.
And that is represented by this and many other photos.
Well,
these are key stories in modern poetry.
And there interestingly interlocking,
just as their two lives were
another modern poet.
This is,
this is an old woman called Marianne Moore,
uh,
who became a kind of civic icon,
who became a celebrity even,
uh,
as an eccentric New Yorker who wore,
try cornered hats and went to baseball games and the zoo,
uh,
and,
here,
uh,
appears in,
well her hair braided and wrapped around her a fanciful,
virginal,
kindly safely out of fashion,
uh,
full of,
of a kind of civic virtue.
The embodiment of a certain kind of popular idea of poetry and you can't read
it,
but there's a kind of stamp of approval here from the governor Nelson
Rockefeller.
Uh,
think of how far away this is from Ezra pound in Saint Elizabeth's hospital.
This is another image of modern poetry,
but,
uh,
more hair was not always done up.
Uh,
this is the image of a child also named Marianne Moore with delicious prodigious
locks.
Uh,
it,
uh,
revealed,
maybe a little bit of the,
uh,
power and extravagance and glory that you feel,
in her poems,
but that she preferred a always to restrain and bind in control,
uh,
in,
extraordinary ways and not always to hide.
Uh,
one of the enduring works,
uh,
written in 1922,
the amazing year that the wasteland and Ulysses appeared in the criterion
started as publication.
One of those amazing works,
uh,
is Marianne Moore's poem called poetry.
You've got to a sample of it on your handout more,
uh,
who revised or pumps just the same way she ended up binding her hair,
republish this poem.
Eventually in short form a very short,
uh,
were three pages.
We were reduced to two sentences.
The first two sentences,
you see,
I too dislike it.
There are things important beyond all this fiddle reading it.
However,
with a perfect contempt for it,
one discovers in it after all,
a place for the genuine,
some of what she cut out of the poem,
uh,
Co cut out of its later version a is a list of what she had in mind as the
genuine,
as examples of it,
uh,
which is the first quotation there,
again on your handout,
the bat holding on upside down,
uh,
and so on,
flee the baseball fan,
the status Titian,
nor is it valid to discriminate against business documents in school books.
All of these phenomenon are important.
The drive to include the world,
uh,
more omnivorous poems,
claim for poetry,
all the subjects that she mentions here,
and indeed many,
many more.
All these are new modern subjects because they represent dimensions,
experience formerly excluded from the elevated idealized discourse that is
poetry,
dimensions of experience,
excluded as prosaic,
more,
uh,
is quoting here,
in that phrase,
business documents in school books as she,
uh,
tells us from Tolstoy,
a prose writer.
Uh,
but she goes further than Tolstoy in her commitment to the seeming lean on
poetic.
She will not only include Tolstoy's pro,
she will not even discriminate against business documents and school books.
Uh,
more exemplifies in this way a key aspect of modern poetry.
It's radical heterogeneity.
Uh,
its will to mix many kinds of materials and discourses,
uh,
to make poetry reach out from the,
rarefied in limited domain of the poetic to,
uh,
keep including more and more of the world.
The next quotation on your handout,
this is another example of this.
Uh,
I won't sing for you,
uh,
or,
or give you my Italian,
uh,
but these,
these famous lines,
uh,
London Bridge is falling down,
falling down,
and so on.
These come from the conclusion to the wasteland.
They,
uh,
they thrust together different,
different texts,
different languages,
writing from different historical periods,
all their compressed in that remarkable,
uh,
mad song.
That concludes the poem.
In the next quotation,
Elliott tells us that a various in complex civilization such as ours produces,
he says,
various and complex results,
uh,
as if inevitably,
lest we think that there's anything particularly forced or outlandish or
willful,
uh,
about his own.
Uh,
uh,
a remarkable poetry,
in Lyons such as those I just quoted for you.
Elliot was there in that essay on the metaphysical poets and I'm quoting from a
defending as necessary.
Uh,
what is the primary characteristic,
not only of his own poetry but really a modern poetry generally what is often
called it's difficulty,
whatever else it may be.
Everyone's always agreed that modern poetry is difficult.
You will probably to,
uh,
by difficult it is meant I think,
well first of all that is in some sense set apart from common speech as a
specialized and highly self conscious use of language.
Elliot would go further and say that there is no common form of modern speech
and that's the problem.
According to Elliot,
the modern world lacks a center.
I kind of set of collective beliefs and commitments,
uh,
that would enable communication between us.
Modernity for Elliot,
as for more,
as for pound is marked by a profusion of languages,
both national languages such as French or Russian,
uh,
which turn up in the wasteland.
Also a bewildering array of specialized types of discourse,
technicals,
genres,
varieties of speech,
business documents.
In school books just begin.
Uh,
this,
there's an extraordinary,
uh,
sense of,
verbal,
uh,
chaos,
a kind of word horde that modern poetry and modernism,
uh,
generally a kind of linguistic environment of great complexity from which,
modern poetry and modernism emerge.
A,
this is an image,
uh,
called Rotterdam,
by the,
uh,
artist,
Edward wants,
where it's a woodcut image from blast.
Uh,
I like it because it's the kind of image of the modern city that makes the
modern city look like language and look like letters,
look like a kind of scout scattered alphabet,
uh,
kind of babble it rep.
It's a,
it's a kind of picture for me of the linguistic environment,
if you will,
of modern poetry behind this environment are the great social processes of
migration and modernization that produced that new urban form,
the metropolis,
all of the poets we read,
even that New England Hayseed Robert Frost,
uh,
begin their careers in metropolitan centers,
primarily in London and New York.
All that is solid,
melts into air.
Karl Marx said,
uh,
evoking the accelerating transformation of modern economic and social life.
The metropolis is the center of this unsettled world that Mark's describes
coming to the metropolis a hundred or 90,
uh,
years ago now,
entailed for the writers that will be reading as much as for anyone else kind of
break with a world that they had known a break either with a native language.
This is what the immigrant or the,
uh,
ex Patriot experiences or perhaps with native ways of speaking and knowing,
familiar spheres of reference life in the modern metropolis was d familiarizing,
uh,
it,
Dean naturalized language,
uh,
where there are many languages in use.
Well,
uh,
language comes to seem arbitrary rather than natural as the product of
convention,
not as something you were simply born into,
but something that you learn,
something that is made and that can be remade.
Uh,
this is a presumption of all the poets we'll be reading modern American writers
and artists,
uh,
immigrated famously,
to London,
to Paris.
Uh,
another key event in the making of modernism is the great migration of African
Americans from the rural south to the urban north.
Uh,
Langston Hughes.
His poetry comes out of this experience.
Uh,
in the community of black intellectuals and artists,
it created specifically in Harlem.
And you'll see on your handout two quotations from poems by Hughes.
Uh,
the first,
uh,
of one 25th street,
giving us,
uh,
well here,
images of black life in the rural south transposed to Harlem.
Uh,
there's,
uh,
in those images,
I think a kind of Utopian promise that the familiar ordinary pleasures,
a rural life can be recaptured in a new society of plenty,
but it's also something hallucinatory and troubling about those images and
vaguely disturbing,
uh,
that's brought out,
I think in the,
uh,
related,
famous poem Harlem on the,
uh,
next side of the page where,
well,
if we've had faces as,
as food,
uh,
in,
in the first,
uh,
text,
something,
possibly reassuring,
uh,
those faces,
begin to look like dangerous objectification in the second one,
uh,
where,
that raisin in the sun threatens to explode.
Metropolis is in modern poetry,
uh,
set against a backdrop of war and violence and conflict and,
modern poetry as it absorbs the world of the metropolis absorbs that,
uh,
that,
violence and energy,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
the metropolis.
Well,
it is,
it's a,
it's a place of ambivalence,
a place of promise and a threat,
uh,
of exaltation.
And also of dread.
This ambivalence that I'm describing is,
is that the,
the center of modern literature generally the metropolis,
uh,
is crowded with language crowded with faces,
but there's also a pervasive sense of absence,
uh,
and of loneliness and of loss captured also Perry dogmatically in the wasteland.
Uh,
and I've included,
uh,
they're,
more lines from that poem,
the Nymphs or departed.
Elliot says,
uh,
Elliot's speaking of a spiritual and imaginative state,
modern poetry arise is in Elliot's case with the death of God,
uh,
with the loss of a theological justification for life with a sense of
disenchantment,
uh,
sense of depletion,
depletion of meaning and value the metropolis which uproots people takes them
away.
It takes them out of traditional cultures.
Also uproots traditional religious belief.
And practices,
Elliot's poetry,
the poetry he created out of this experience as a poetry of spiritual agony.
Modernity is in his work,
uh,
a condition of social and psychological fragmentation,
which is both,
uh,
both a private personal dilemma in,
in a public one as he understands it
compare to Elliot's city,
uh,
Elliot sense of the city.
This one,
this is a photograph by Alfred Stieglitz,
uh,
city of ambition.
Uh,
this is the modern cities not as a scene of fragmentation or despair,
uh,
but rather a place of ascent and aspiration.
It's also a scene of crossings,
uh,
bridging past and future.
This is a photo by another American photographer,
Walker Evans,
a photo of Brooklyn Bridge.
You recognize it.
Uh,
uh,
and here is another,
another image,
uh,
by Evans of the bridge.
This one comes from a page of heart cranes,
epic poem,
the bridge,
uh,
and,
and uh,
uh,
a book that you can go find it at.
Meineke remarkable,
uh,
addition of cranes poem,
where,
uh,
Evans photos,
grand photos appear.
It's almost miniature images surrounded by white space.
Uh,
as you get some sense in this image
in crane,
in his great poem,
the bridge.
And here's another photo by Evans,
this time of crane,
uh,
on the rooftop of the apartment building in Brooklyn,
one 10,
Columbia Heights where he lived and where he began the poem with the bridge in
the background,
uh,
in crane.
And the emphasis is not on what is lost and modernity,
but what found or what might be,
here's a,
uh,
another quotation from,
your handout.
Number seven,
new thresholds,
new anatomies wine talons build freedom up about me and distill this competence
to travel in a tear,
sparkling alone within another's will.
Modern poetry is difficult.
Uh,
and,
and these are difficult lines.
New thresholds,
new anatomies.
Well,
that's not such a hard concept.
That's an,
an image of what the modern promises for crane.
And indeed those,
uh,
Gothic arches of the bridge seem to emblem Matteis for him,
yet crane's poetry and those lines I just read really are difficult,
uh,
just as a,
as Elliot and pound or difficult.
Uh,
uh,
but,
not because as in those poets,
uh,
crane presents us with obscure references,
war,
uh,
languages unknown to us,
um,
or learned illusion instead.
What's difficult in crane as a kind of compression,
uh,
in his writing,
they,
they show us a,
a poet taking language apart and putting it back together in new ways.
New configurations,
new anatomies.
A crane is full of mixed metaphors.
You know,
you're not supposed to mix your metaphors well.
Uh,
he does all the time.
Wine talents.
There's one wine towns.
What are they?
Well,
uh,
think about it.
Uh,
perhaps you too have felt wine talents grip you unexpectedly sometime and carry
you a loft.
The Metaphor suggests ecstasy,
the exaltation of Modern Life.
That aspiration in,
uh,
imaged in Stieglitz to,
it suggests that ecstasy is like wine in wine is like an eagle.
Clasping you,
its prey in its claws.
And keep in mind when crane wrote those lines too,
it was illegal to buy and sell wine in this country.
Uh,
modernity in,
in cranes,
strange,
gorgeous poetry is all about getting high about elevation exaltation.
Crane was an alcoholic.
And if you study this photo,
uh,
you can,
you can see the,
the,
uh,
qualities,
of a man,
um,
uh,
struggling with alcoholism,
this,
this friendly and even dignified face,
uh,
have prematurely white hair.
Uh,
his cheeks are veins,
uh,
being drunk became for crane,
a kind of grim literalization of the freedom that came with being modern.
Uh,
and that vision of,
of,
uh,
freedom,
is something that has poetry preserves for us and,
and,
and carries forward for us.
And,
uh,
continues to give us as a gift contrast his images of joyous or demonic ascent
with the images of catastrophe,
of dissent,
uh,
of,
of collapse in Elliot London.
Bridge is falling down.
The decay of,
of Christian belief and practice,
uh,
is not,
a loss,
but rather an opportunity for poetry in crane.
Uh,
he says,
uh,
in the bridge,
he,
he asks the Bridge to lend the myth to God.
Uh,
any suggests that this is something that every age must do a because our names
for God are always metaphors,
poems,
something imagined.
Uh,
acts of speech poet,
uh,
crane shares these general ideas with Wallace Stevens,
this as well.
Uh,
Steven's,
uh,
while Stevens who said poetry is a means of redemption and meant it,
Steven's,
uh,
began life,
well as a choir boy,
uh,
and as a Christian.
But his work is all about replacing Christian theology with poetry for Stevens
when at he takes away God.
What it does is unveil the poets,
godlike powers,
a power to create the world through imagination,
uh,
imagination which created God in the first place in Steven's.
Modernity's shows us that the truth of religion was always a fiction,
a fundamentally poetic construction.
Stevens,
his world is secular and non transcendental,
uh,
and he is fully at home in it.
So much so that,
uh,
he lives the life of a,
where's Ua businessmen as,
uh,
an executive of the Hartford accident and indemnity,
company,
uh,
a great Connecticut Burger and poet,
Steven's celebrates the bourgeois world over and over again in a poetry that is
about in itself enacts,
uh,
our perpetual recreation of reality through the mind and its special medium
language.
Uh,
Stephens,
he understands tragedy.
Uh,
but he is a comic poet,
a humanist who is concerned to preserve and exalt the human,
uh,
the relativity of truth,
the profusion of languages,
these things that,
uh,
afflict Elliot,
are a source of faith for Steven's
modern poetry seeks absolutes.
What Moore calls the genuine,
what crane calls the myth of America.
Uh,
the voice of the thunder in Elliot a Stevens is supreme fiction,
uh,
pounds.
Cantos a poem that would,
as he intended include history.
Modern poetry is in all these ways.
Promethian astounding,
a arrogant,
uh,
enormous,
imprudent visionary.
But it also contains other positions,
uh,
alternatives that,
that open those oversized cultural ambitions to critique,
uh,
to,
imaginative,
uh,
alternatives of many kinds.
And these are suggested,
uh,
I'll suggest briefly,
by the last two poets,
we'll read,
uh,
wh Auden,
to begin with here pictured as an Oxford undergraduate,
ever cheeky,
uh,
who has written on the side of his photo,
the cerebral life would pay
dry,
cool,
pragmatic and Elizabeth Bishop,
uh,
young in this glamorous George Platt Lynes photo.
While modern poetry in many of its forms strives to master reality.
Arden reminds us there and your handout cautiously that poetry makes nothing
happen while Steven's represents the poet as a kind of God.
Bishop sees the poet rather as a sand piper.
Uh,
that little bird,
a skittering along the shore,
not in control of the world,
but subject to it,
subject to its continual fluctuation and awesome powers.
A Bishop Piper poet there I knew in your handout is,
is obsessed with the mere details of experience.
Those sand grains,
quartz grains.
Uh,
her aim is to get along in a world that is dominated by shifting forces that can
be registered in,
reacted to by poetry,
but not explained.
Uh,
this is,
I think really also aversion of poetic activity that has some sources in and has
a lot in common with Robert Frost's,
uh,
as we will see on Monday.
Thank you.